qui vous écoutent à la maison qui
comprennent pas pourquoi c'est si long
consulé vos instances qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire là de façon pratique pratique
il y a 100000 membres dans la coalition
réparti d'environ une soixantaine
d'associations étudiantes ces gens-là
doivent se consulter dans chacune de
leurs association étudiantes et tous ces
gens-là doivent après ça revenir
ensemble et prendre une décision
collective ça prend du temps oui mais la
démocratie parfois ça prend du temps et
Madame beauchan après 9 semaines de
silence
total n'est pas légitime de nous laisser
seulement 24 heures pour consulter c'est
vraiment une attitude je crois qui qui
qui a un manque de respect mais pourquoi
la fe est capable de consulter ses
instances en ce moment même pourquoi la
feu qui a été capable d'envoyer un
communiqué ce matin en disant nous
condamnons et vous vous êtes pas cap Ava
peut-être des consultations de fait au
préalable dans ces organisations là le
fonctionnement des fédérations
étudiantes et de la classe n'est pas
exactement le même nous fonctionnons
selon un principe du côté de la classe
vraiment de démocratie directe alors
nous on ne renira pas nos principes pour
satisfaire une condition qui est
superficielle et purement symbolique
nous allons prendre le temps de faire
les choses comme il faut de consul les
étudiants et les étudiantes et lorsque
notre position changera si elle change
parce que c'est loin d'être assuré ce
sera annoncé à Madame beauchan